if one of y'all says some silly ass
name this whole class is gonna feel
my wrath now d nice
do you mean denise me
i am your substitute
mr nostrom
but that might as well say no nonsense
because i do not
play now today will not
be a day off in fact today
you will work harder than
somebody call a cold
all right listen up y'all i'm your
substitute teacher mr garvey
i taught school for 20 years in the
inner city
so don't even think about messing with
me you all feel me
mm-hmm okay let's take a roll here
jay quellon
where's jayquillinette no jay quellon
here
yeah uh do you mean jacqueline
okay so that's how it's gonna be y'all
wanna play
okay then i've got my eye on you
jaqueline
balake where is bolaca
at there's no blocker here today
yes sir my name is blake
are you out of your goddamn mind blake
what do you want to go to war blocky no
cause we could go to war
no i'm for real i'm for real
so you better check yourself
d nice is there a d
nice if one of y'all
says some silly ass name
this whole class is going to feel my
wrath
now d nice do you mean denise [ __ ]
you say your name right right now denise
say it right
denise correctly denise right denise
right d
nice that's better thank you now
a-a-ron where are you
where is a-a-ron right now
no a-a-ron huh well you better be
sick dead or mute a-a-ron
yeah oh man
why didn't you answer me the first time
i said huh huh i'm just you know i'm
just asking you i said it like four
times so why didn't you say it
the first time i said a-a-ron
because it's pronounced aaron sonner
you done messed up hey ron now take your
ass on down to osac hennessey's office
right now and tell him exactly what you
did
who oh shaq hennessy
principal o'shaughnessy get out of my
goddamn classroom before i break my foot
off in your ass
insubordinate and churlish
timothy present
thank you the right triangle's longest
side
is called the hypotenuse and it's this
side here
let's see the longest one i wish i were
high
on pot noose i wish i was high on pot
[Applause]
news
okay okay okay oh mr morrison's very
funny it's very funny but
let's get back to the lesson if you can
see
the longest one where it goes from this
point that was my joke
i know man that was hilarious of a
triangle i've labeled them here a b and
c no but i mean i said that i labeled
anything
i said it say that i said it i said that
please please mr jackson keep your
comments to yourself
thank you ah now the
[Laughter]
hypotenuse
you really got me on that one oh so
great
oh oh principal martel principal martel
come here come here come here
uh tell principal martel what you said
troy oh uh
um she was talking about the hypotenuse
and i said i wish i was high on pot news
[Applause]
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
he likes it principal martel's cool
that's very funny principle martell
principal martel
i said that mr jackson that is enough
what i said at first oh uh mr iglesias
mr iglesias yes
come in come in yeah yes what's up
people's
coffee comedian gabriel iglesias is
touring the local schools today for a
charity he's working on
tell him what you said tell me what you
said oh
i wish i was high on pot noose
oh my god that is clever that is good
very funny
really funny right no thanks mr iglesias
mr gracias
uh i'm your biggest fan that was my joke
uh you know it's not really cool buddy
to take credit for other people's jokes
hey listen funny stuff i'm doing this
big tour right now
you want to see about maybe we could
talk about your opening i need an opener
oh um sure what do you think is that
okay
of course what
sorry about that hey talent nice to meet
you thanks so much richard pryor get
over here man come on
uh he deserved it all right so across
from the longest side
is a 90 degree angle
good thing i've got a 90 degree dangle
yo
stop it you will never be troy why are
you trying to be like troy
dick a two nerdy girl
so the hypotenute
right here oh my god
i'm gonna take a little roll here jay
cuellar
here you are present
blocky right here uh-huh
d-nice here good
jessica thank you
mr garvey what is a.a ron
some of us need to leave uh a few
minutes early today
oh oh is that
so mm-hmm and what
pray tell is the reason
for this premature exodus yearbook
photos
um we have to leave 15 minutes early to
meet up with our clubs
all right you know what that might work
with other substitute teachers
but i taught in the inner city for over
20 years
now y'all want to leave my class early
so y'all can go
meet up at the club
ain't none of y'all old enough to go to
the damn club
ridiculous mr garvey god
son of a [ __ ] did us
doctor just then yes i'm gonna throw you
out the goddamn window
what jay quinlan mr garvey we're telling
the truth we
we have clubs at this school we have
clubs for special interests
okay i see so y'all want to play y'all
want to play yeah okay we're going to
play little games
fine i'll play i'm more than happy to
play some games with y'all
anyone who's in a club stands your ass
up
uh-huh oh yeah there it is there it is
the usual suspects what the hell club
are you in
jaquelin future leaders of america
okay okay how would you know
if you're going to be a leader in the
future
is there a stargate in your bedroom
can you travel through town jay kwellen
no just [ __ ] the flip down
but like i don't here's the thing i
don't even know why i'm about to ask you
this
but lockheed what club are you in uh i'm
part of the spanish club
sp this you about as spanish as rion
seacrest
with your big-ass fraggle rock hair
how about you d nice i'm in the chess
club
uh i'm sorry sweetheart you are
not in the chest the mosquito bite club
maybe
oh it's hurtful truthful
there he is hey ron
hey what club are you in
i'm the president of the glee club why
do i talk the glee club
like they gonna have a club dedicated
to a tv show take your ass to osha
hennessy's office right now before i
bust a club
up in your butt okay no okay here you go
mischievous and deceitful chicanerous
and deplorable this is principal
o'shaughnessy
students please report to the gymnasium
for your club photos fake announcement
now does anybody in here have a valid
reason
for leaving this classroom timothy i got
to go pick up my daughter
your skin
okay all right everybody just uh let's
settle down
settle in and like just totally let's
get our math on okay
all right guys so um
all right somebody's got a little extra
energy from phys ed right
jimmy buddy hey buddy let's okay let's
just let's knock it off okay
okay you got me he got me right guys
jimmy dude all right let's take our seat
[Music]
that's great bounce free that's great
very
[Applause]
that was awesome oh and i thank you i
thank you for the entertainment man
[Music]
i don't want to harsh your vibe man but
ah eureka
i'm gonna be honest with you really
pushing my buttons now
jimmy baby you're driving me crazy
[Applause]
okay jimmy do you want me to call
principal martel
that would not be bitching wouldn't it
you know what timmy you know what why
don't you come up and teach the class
man
wouldn't that be awesome
yeah come on
no and then you know what i'm gonna do
jimmy i'll just sit here how about that
jimmy and then we can
all watch how you're being disrupted
oh i see that's supposed to be me right
all right jimmy okay i see that i get it
supposed to be me it's time to be done
jimmy
don't you dare johnny
oh yeah oh yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i'm
[Laughter]
how about that huh that's you jimmy i'm
jimmy
i'm jimmy and i need attention
yeah i'm jenny i'm jimmy hello look at
him i'm gonna be happy movie that's the
funniest thing that ever happened
mr flyer principal martel no what
no no no no no no it was jimmy it was
jimmy principal martel
no jimmy why yeah it was jenna hey
it was jimmy it was jimmy
[Applause]
[Music]
daddy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you